twitch you want to know my favorite
thing that we've added
it's you
Ellen DeGeneres is mourning the death of
her friend and former colleague Steven
twitch boss I've watched this woman work
day in and day out and how tedious she
is about details and making sure that
making sure that things are right and
for me I pick up on that she's still
very much involved very much Hands-On
very meticulous and I love that shortly
after news broke on Wednesday that
twitch died by Suicide the TV
personality reacted on Twitter writing
that she is heartbroken adding quote
twitch was pure love and Delight he was
my family and I loved him with all my
heart I will miss him twitch served as
the house DJ on The Ellen Degeneres Show
from 2014 until the series ended earlier
this year becoming an executive producer
on the show in the process
just as usual absolutely
Ellen ended her message asking fans to
send love and support to twitch's wife
Allison holker and the three children
they shared I'm just so proud of all of
them the show is amazing they do so many
amazing things Allison released a
statement on Wednesday reflecting on The
Life and Legacy of her husband writing
that he lit up every room he stepped
into adding that he valued family
friends and Community Above All Else and
leading with love and light was
everything to him I have the sweetest
husband in the entire world Allison
concluded her emotional statement with
one final message to her other half we
love you we miss you and I will always
Save the Last Dance For You I feel like
we connect a lot through dance so it's
just sometimes fun like to have a
partner in life that I can also dance
with you know it just makes every single
day so fun
now asaurus tells E.T the cast of
Dancing With the Stars is rallying
around Allison who spent four years as a
pro on the series our source says the
dancers are devastated confused and
feeling so many emotions as for Allison
The Source says she's beside herself and
feels like she is living a nightmare
quote twitch was such a genuine and
good-hearted person and his loved ones
are feeling his tremendous loss
meanwhile some of twitch's famous
friends are sharing their condolences on
social media Viola Davis and Questlove
tweeted their at a loss for words
foreign
shared that clip on Tick Tock writing
that she's crushed meanwhile Lonnie Love
posted several clips from twitch's 40th
birthday bash in September and sent her
love and support to his family I'm still
in a lot of shock
um my daughter is really close with
Wesley his daughter and our kids went to
school together and he and I went to
college together and um
yeah it's a lot so
ET was with boss's longtime friend Jody
Sweetin shortly after the tragic news
broke he's such a talent and such an
amazing warm wonderful heart and yeah he
will be he will be greatly missed and
social media personality Tabitha Brown
fought back tears leaving fans with a
message of hope I want to encourage
anybody out there right now who you are
thinking about giving up
it will get better